SPEAKER: In this video,
we'll discuss account hold
and how to communicate this
account status with your user.
A subscription
begins account hold
when a user's form of payment
fails and grace period has
ended.
You should block access
to your content or service
while a user is in account hold.
Users will automatically
receive access again
when the payment
method is fixed.
This can encourage users to
update their payment method
without canceling their
subscription, which can
lead to greater user retention.
If a user has multiple
subscriptions in account
hold due to an issue with
the same payment method--
for example, an
expired credit card--
then fixing that
payment method once
will restore all of
the subscriptions
for all of the
user's apps connected
to that particular
payment method.
Apps that do not enable account
hold cannot be automatically
restored when a user
fixes their payment.
We recommend enabling both
grace period and account hold.
Account hold will begin after
the grace period has ended.
To activate account hold,
sign into your Play console,
and select your app.
On the left menu, click store
presence, in-app products.
Select the subscriptions tab,
and expand the subscription
settings section.
Then check the activate
account hold check box.
With real-time
developer notifications,
you'll receive a notification
when a subscription enters
account hold.
Call the Google
Play Developer API
from your server to record the
new subscription information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You should then provide
a message in your app
that tells the user that there
is a problem with their payment
information.
Be sure to include a deep link
to the Google Play Subscription
Center so the user can
fix their payment method.
For more information on
setting up deep links,
visit the link onscreen.
It's important to note that
if users expect your app
to perform services
outside the app,
such as sending your user a
notification for stock market
alerts or notifying them when
their favorite team is playing,
you may want to send a push
notification or an email
to the user to let them
know that their service is
no longer active.
But if your services are
contained within your app,
it might be OK to wait
until the next time they
open the app before
informing them of the issue.
For more information,
visit the link onscreen,
or check out our other videos.